thank you dermot yes sir graham has
announced that the timetable which i
think was as we predicted really the
thing we were waiting for of course was
the number of nominations that
candidates need to get why have you
decided on 20. we're trying to strike a
balance we don't want to make it
impossible for any serious candidate to
enter the contest we thought 20 was a
number that anybody who's got real
support
ought to be able to secure that that
number of mps supporters
but we also want to make sure that we
can move smoothly and reasonably quickly
through the process and we didn't want
to have a cast of thousands in the uh
election a cost of thousands i mean
there's uh 11 at the moment and have you
heard for example is pretty patel
standing i don't know and we will open
and close nominations tomorrow so we'll
have a clear picture by close to play
tomorrow of just how many of those uh
candidates are uh serious in wanting to
put themselves forward so i assume
you'll open the nominations in the
morning close them in the evening is
that the plan what are the times that
you're thinking of we're going to have
nomination uh appointments fixed so we
want to be able to check that people's
nominations are valid and confirm that
at the time so to be a slightly
different process so tomorrow evening
you'll be able to say these are the
candidates who have been validly
nominated
and um are you planning any husting say
on wednesday when mps are voting
in case we have a very large field in
the first instance we won't be having
hustings before the first ballot on
wednesday
we will have hustings following that
ahead of the second round
so probably on wednesday evening we'll
be uh offering us and you've said to get
to the second ballot and the candidates
will need to get 30. why did you decide
on that number again we want to see a
reasonable progression we want to see
that people are picking up support
beyond the 20 who've nominated
but we don't want to make it a
ludicrously high barriers so
we debated it at some length and and
arrived at 30 as a a reasonable
compromise you debated it at some length
does that mean some of your colleagues
wanted a higher number
i think initially the proposition had
been put that we might make a ten
percent of the party which would be six
or seven six yeah uh we decided to make
a little bit easier to meet the
threshold today how many rounds of
voting do you think you'll need i
suppose it depends on how the numbers go
it it really does but i think experience
suggests that those candidates that
have lesser levels of support tend to
identify that fairly early on so i hope
that we will be in that position early
next week
and certainly we will get to two
candidates
before the house of commons rises for
the summer on the 21st of july now you
had a lengthy meeting with the board um
did they want a longer process for the
party members we had a discussion about
how we could optimize it get the
candidate chosen before the house comes
back on the fifth of when the house
comes back on the 5th of september
but also make sure that we were going to
have plenty of opportunities for members
of the voluntary party to question and
meet the candidates at hustings meetings
all over the united kingdom uh i think
we've arrived at a good compromise and
it's september the fifth the day that
boris johnson will leave downing street
uh
it is the day that we will elect a new
leader of the conservative party i think
it's reasonable to assume that that
might take place but obviously we
can't speak for the palace which will
clearly be involved in uh making
arrangements queen normally gets to
balmoral round about that time and the
prime minister often goes early
september don't they i have had uh some
preliminary discussions uh
just to make sure that we we uh are
uh confident that we won't cause uh
unnecessary inconvenience so you spoke
to the palace uh i i've had some
discussions but not necessarily directly
with the past you also said in answer to
questions a few moments ago that you
wanted an assurance from the top two who
go to the ballot of the members that one
of them won't pull out that was what
andrea ledson did a few years ago didn't
she yes you know the trouble with that
is you end up with the voluntary party
not having the opportunity to quiz the
candidates not having that more
protracted period of scrutiny and it's
uh obviously beneficial uh to to be able
to do that we will do it over a
relatively short period uh but it
will take place in time for the uh
leader to be in
position
when the house comes back on the 5th of
september so graham thank you for
speaking to sky news thank you very much
there you go there is sir graham brady
explaining how the whole thing's going
to work